I think that it's okay you can know
somebody's heart
the next said this before but the heart
and the dick are two completely separate
things and what somebody does when
they're trying to the heart inside your
body the dicks outside yeah two
different things of course they are yeah
but I mean look it's not inside your
heart yeah well his is kinda yeah the
casing it was fat yeah it was this like
no really yeah cuz we are fat covers the
I mean that's not really doesn't make it
an interior no I wasn't do you know
phallus not as a clip i i i i kind of
want to talk about one of the episodes
of black mirror you see the prime
minister we just talked about one prime
because all you say you toss what
episode it's a spoiler alert so people
can a spoiler alert spoiler episodes
called crocodile it's the third one okay
I'm only gonna talk about the first
scene the murder yeah nothing a murder
you know it's not a murder it's two
people in the car oh yeah right right
you and I in a car yeah we just partied
so we're a little drunk right and we're
in the middle of like the desert or
whatever where they were they were in a
canyon a mountainside no cars or no one
around by themself they hit a bicyclists
he dies they put the bicycle list body
in a sleeping bag
they put rocks in it and they just throw
it in the ocean right you call the
police right well they were afraid that
because they were both intoxicated yeah
I know that's what I'm saying you and I
are drugged out that's manslaughter
think you would what would you do me in
that situation I already know myself I
would just turn myself in yeah me too
because that's too much [ __ ] to go
through also generally but if he was an
elite I'm asking this pirate character
yeah I'm gonna be very I will you be
very political sex with a monkey in
Korea and move on next question
question well if it was your desert
you're still in America your New Mexico
okay love that and you run over an
illegal immigrant yeah
and you're drunk I have an answer to
that
that's much better scenario because then
if I'm able to track down his family
it's not like they can sue in America
I'm just gonna provide for the family
for the rest of my life so you hide the
Thomas Shelby it if I can't remember
yeah I'm going to make sure that they're
all taken care of for the rest of their
lives so you bury the body you don't go
to the police but you find his
identification
I don't bury the body I give the body
back to the family hey dude I killed
your boy we know the cook that he
crossed the border as she's saying right
he's now in America right yeah you're
drunk in New Mexico I'm driving that
body back to Mexico I'm getting sick
other people to help me do you know this
man I'm not gonna say I killed him to
everybody but I don't know okay if it's
just internal hemorrhage
I know a row I have to find Rolo's
family I wouldn't turn myself into
American authorities I would not if it
was an illegal layout everywhere I would
I'm trying to think of the most
beneficial way that the family could
benefit the most right yeah me going to
prison will not benefit them because
they don't have a slice of my pie I want
to give him my pie because I [ __ ]
killed their family member and I want to
make I want to pay my dues I want to say
I'm sorry in ways that's going to
improve their life you know what I would
do I just thought of it
this is even better if I had money I
wouldn't mummify his body great listen
hear my story hear me out rise good mama
fires [ __ ] right right have to do and
then you have them like in positions in
your back yard like he's cutting trees
good okay we're boiling the lawn right
right and you sneak photos have a
background right yeah and then you keep
digging you you know is if you send his
money you write a letter you know
you know dear Maria Maria Maria I'm
working so hard you know made for you
know mr. Lisa stay and you know I can
but I have sent you you know mean he's
just a guy right I'll put him in the
background if you can't really see you
know put gloves on him and do you have
any consequences from this no he's he's
gonna be she's gonna get a lot of money
okay trust me I'm talking like Donald
Trump now all right believe me it's
gonna be amazing
yes we amazing he's she's gonna be gonna
get a bunch of money but just rat Raul
is always gonna be the provider not a
good idea I will also give know kind of
like what that's like the dark night
when they killed Harvey Dent was bad
they just said oh that he was the good
guy so they always perceive him as the
good guy that's what I'm saying
you she would benefit I think the family
would benefit more amended the law what
if the family was justicia what's
justice and they're like no I don't want
the money this will you killed my you
know I know but he is not good they're
not gonna know he died he works for me
he'd there's heat there's proof that's
him on the roof you'd be doing the
shingles you know uncle Raul never move
yeah yeah well I would like green screen
of it out fear it out man you killed
somebody
well figure it out let you ever hear
about the guide the guy that mummified
his daughter his daughter died and he
mummified her like what do you call it
um captured taxidermy that's what I
would do I would taxidermy the illegal
immigrant he wouldn't mummified is yeah
I would test that taxidermy but he I
guess maybe there's an urban legend I
don't know but he has her in a red dress
and with a balloon and she's just
sitting there in the living room
standing there in the living room I
think there's a health code that people
have to follow in America that legal
right is what I'm saying like I don't
know I know that obviously taxidermy is
like legal but taxidermy like there's
health codes you have to follow and you
have to like become you have to
get rid of a body in a certain way that
is legal I don't know if taxidermy is
one of them because I feel like more
people would do it if that was the case
if it was I don't think anyone did it's
creepy
I would please taxidermy me I wouldn't
be I haven't talked about this before I
want you to mount me on the wall so my
cats can see me every day and say ah mom
still home yeah you know what my ideas
what put me in a tuxedo I don't get me
one okay and this is what I want you to
do okay put me in a gigantic jar of
formaldehyde okay so I'm just floating
specimen I'm floating and then you have
me in like a Cathedral people can walk
into this little like it's a just a
little chamber but a stone chamber you
walk in in the middle of this chamber
it's gigantic jar with me floating there
in there put a smile on my face if you
can yeah and underneath my body like
outside of this jar is a mechanism we it
says people's names so it'll say Gilbert
George whatever you press on it and I go
what's up George
I like your new custom extra money no
you put eighteen hundred names the
people that you know everyone that you
know even people that I can never get
out what's up kalila then cuz it's not
even programmed in to know he was you
know I I do might know I do before I die
before I die I customize all the I'll do
sentences yeah don't let the Sun fall
down or whatever yeah I'll just have
yeah there's funny raises you think you
would just see me floating in this in
this jar oh my gosh pretty cool just
donate your body to the the human
exhibit no I want people specifically to
come see me
I want strangers oh you in fact if
you're not in the [ __ ] buttons
okay come you can't come in huh better
hope your name is either George kalila
or Gilbert yeah
there'll be a list but um you think oh
no it's your story
I'm just look if anything happens to you
yeah I have to send this audio to court
and be like look this is what he wanted
yeah we have video yeah I can I be in a
jar of [ __ ] formaldehyde it could be
I think if it if it were like a science
experiment there's probably a loophole
to where they because they do that with
the with the body exhibit they keep they
put real bodies there they put real like
babies that have died and things like
that so just download your your memory I
have a question speak download would you
guys if you select consciousness would
you be okay with someone downloading a
digital copy of yourself no I had to
live in this trap digital world no no I
watched episode six okay I am scarred
for life yeah about where my
consciousness goes after this but you
could put my consciousness in an Android
Aarthi say for your consciousness in
Twila like I will have stipulations so
if you collect my consciousness it has
to be and it has to be put into a vessel
that has all the Spanish dick I'm gonna
see oh my god I need to have I need to
have my vessel have full capacity
talking about conscious I only had like
once no know if his conscious was in
your head and like he died and then you
moved on with your life thinking you
have to he'd be in your head talked
about this we watch episode I would
never have him no way I would only do it
I would only do it if she didn't know oh
hell I would never say anything I would
just kick back and watch this movie this
a long ass we're like hiking again she's
in the ocean trying to capture lobsters
you're not gonna get and everyone souls
you'll see Australian and Spanish dick
specifically Australians yeah and I
would I let me say if I'm in her mind
and she's sucking dick do I taste it -
yeah yes no no thank you there's no way
I feel like it would be like you would
consider that a gift but then every
right and every night you see her open
up a tire
and has your face in it and she said to
tear no I got it I think she's gonna
[ __ ] forget about me
and that's the sad truth I love how you
say that
[Music]